hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play cry of fear okay now I want
you to listen to this for sink this is
weird hear that hear that it's Simon's
breathing I think but anyway I don't
know what what the deal is with that but
either way I'm still in the woods no oh
god no oh no no no no no a million times
no nope nope nope
I swear to Aisha you send the chainsaw
man after me oh no no no no no no no no
no no no no no oh no no no nope nope I
got a doorknob uh why the arrow that oh
that's where the chief
what what what what what what good dude
I didn't even hear him it was there Oh
too early in the episode to be starting
this okay I hear you chainsaw man yeah I
suppose you come I don't know why my
stick keeps breaking it's not stickable
look there goes okay oh man it's too
early in the game to be dealing with
this the arrow is pointing in the wrong
direction I went that way
I saw nothing of the use oh boy
okay now he's gonna pop up out of
nowhere
I want the help look out what now I
can't move I give up oh I'm out of
running dude loud and proud now Oh
oh I'm so not going the right way okay
buddy are you by her right there
No where do I go what do I do
ah
oles know where you leave nowhere it's a
lot ok ok I'm ok ok the song as I don't
hit any balls like those walls the walls
they might not be walls ah ha ha hey
buddy hey how you doin
what's going on with you been a while oh
man oh yeah how's the family
I see kids I swear I swear I went
towards the arrow and it did nothing oh
hello ok so if I just go straight I'm
not moving just going straight wherever
it wherever it wants me to go
Robbie sees me right to the wall oh holy
crap ah come on ok I got it
ok how do I lose the guy I won't have
time to get into my inventory and do
anything come on sticks
okay I won't it like it I won't have
time to get to my inventory I won't have
time
maybe if I just spam my use button on
the door it'll work
straight don't deviate from the path at
all not a bit
come on bring it on I know there yeah
okay
oh damn it
come here yeah here buddy okay and then
just come on I need a door not open ACK
how the hell if I quit the door mom
Oh No
okay well I'm gonna do is I'm gonna like
backtrack a bit first let's see if I can
backtrack a bit get him to come close to
me and then try to lose him like way
back here there is whoa hello oh come on
I can't what the hell kind of springy
with nowhere maybe it doesn't allow me
to spring that would be too easy
oh come on away from that guy there like
a shortcut to use [ __ ] damn it there
like a shortcut to use something in my
inventory maybe maybe if I go through
the door hang on let me try that that's
probably that's probably it
okay let's just go backwards after after
door man open the door maybe he'll be on
come on what what is this look at this
guys I'm pressing the W button and it
just doesn't allow me to go whatever you
don't matter it don't matter okay what
the hell what the hell where to go
over here oh here it is
I go through the door maybe I'll do away
from him
could hope not
oh don't be like this
where's the damn door where's the damn
door give me there so I got a doorknob
Manus get
I can't I'm not gonna be alone people
like make it put the doorknob on the
stick put the doorknob and combine the
doorknob all right let's try I know he's
still here haha human sounds like way
downrange
oh come on guys great alright try I'm
gonna try to get instantaneous open
inventory right get out of here damn it
nothing look at him look at this [ __ ]
lock it up okay not damn it I didn't
even get a chance open my inventory what
do I do
baloney ah
honey how do you want to step with me Oh
what do I do now I gotta beat him with
us
dick seriously he's like in so fast he
instantly catches up to me let me just
go without grabbing the door maybe he's
there oh oh no you're gonna pop up yep
there is
so that it
hello
now trying to sprint
he's right by me yeah he didn't even
matter that I sprinted
ah I like you bring you the stick Emma
yeah back Oh
taunting me
I gotta be doing something wrong
cuz
and they just think about this there's
literally no way to get away from he
instantly catches up to me I gotta try
to like get him caught on some geometry
long enough that I can get away because
that's happened before in the cities
he's like stopped I just got to figure
out how to get him to skits got you that
gold I get stuck on the dirt like right
here a very reliable place to get stuck
he see it's just like I don't know what
this is all about but it's completely
repeatable oh shut up guy yeah bring it
welcome Bryant come on come on
Oh
I have on it pass that trait god dammit
stuck again
all right come on I'm just gonna run
around with you
you get stuck here you seem even faster
than you used to
we get tired of chasing me around
gosh darn it I got like no time okay
i'ma try it
Oh God
stupid trees bull honkey I would hate
for this whole episode is just me me
trying to get past this guy
it looks like it's turning out to be
that way
oh I hate you reproducible errors okay I
need the door mom get in there how fast
can I spam the doorknob question
I come on
Ben okay all right ah it's like double
bash this time around don't get it okay
I'm gonna try to sprint full or again
come on buddy
come on pal friendo where yeah where
yeah where yeah where yeah where you
there yet
let's straight forward zoomy zoomy soon
as I get to the door just come on use it
you that yes I get it I got it yeah yes
Oh get away
don't even try bro don't even try don't
even try
don't try it huh oh man oh I thought I
was doomed I got there and I
accidentally dropped it on the combine
oh thank you okay
you recognize that that last part was
kind of stupid need to give me safe
I can do that too not so scary Oh hahaha
oh you're a lady in white when you're
moving you're moving fast no dick
go you're Duke gun ah come on
there you go good golly oh [ __ ] nope
nope nope
he's weird breathing got here I got some
dick step ah damn I'm gonna die die die
damn it don't kill me
gah I don't have any syringes please
tell me there's a syringe full of like
heroin God D remember that my dad uh
Emmett Emmett uh can you move okay don't
die come on ahh Oh die die I'm just
going for the door great good it screwed
I'm going for the door don't I can't
even move fast anymore oh don't don't
don't do where'd you go oh you're right
there
where'd you go there yard like flashing
in and up okay
alright let's just have a truce here you
stay there and [ __ ] right off
drop me oh damn it oh damn it that's
weird
I'm gonna die I'm gonna die
shut up suck it up so you got a few
knife wounds Oh big whoop
oh that looks scary damn it
uh-huh anything else out here find out
all over yourself
maybe there was something in this
abandoned building but I don't look yeah
ah there we go - got it
bunch of weirdos Fraga bring it on bring
it when I'm ready - for you - brand
oh damn it come on coop market goddamn
it Adam Oh God
can't you take two down for I'll need
two there is the other one and come on
Oh get out of the woods okay slash twice
and then you ought you stay right there
yeah yeah well Pond you pärnu yeah
exploit Punk you got stuck get it get
some stay there they're gay they're okay
I'm gonna hit you that's some nice duct
tape dress you got there boy I bet you
guys lined up to take you to prom
oh damn it fine stay there just date
stay there ah ah duck Kim you have crap
ha ha ha Oh got you oh I got you so
hardcore they all have knives why can't
I get their knife oh very full I need to
use this tool Oh dark OOP area I hope I
hit my arm
yes okay I don't need the other half of
the scissors it's sharp
I'm gonna go back and save wherever it
was theirs oh can I get in there no
don't tell me I can't get in there oh
come on come on jump there we go okay
thank you
this is cooperating all right that's all
the time I got for this part so thank
you so much for watching and I will see
you in the next part
bye bye